the James Franco Comedy Central Roast
was last week and it takes a lot for me
to get offended I am a comedian I
believe in free speech I I can't even
write honestly can't remember the last
time I was truly offended by by words
and not actions but I was watching this
thing and it was just an endless
onslaught of gay joke after gay joke
after gay joke but don't take my word
for it let's watch to prepare for his
role in 127 hours he told me he spent
five days with his arm inside the rock
he goes by Dwayne Johnson now I can't
forget in this world there can only be
one James Franco because if there were
two James Franco's they'd never stopped
book each other
James recently won the ally award for
his support of the LGBT community it's a
prestigious award that's given annually
annually
James is openly a very sexual person I
don't think James is necessarily gay or
straight I think he just he literally
can't open his eyes enough to see who
he's gay
James you're hard to roast I mean you're
so dreamy I mean something about you I
just want to please you I just want to
take you back to my hotel room take off
all your clothes and let a man do okay
that is just a small snippet of the
endless night of gay jokes you know gay
people are fighting for equality and
comedy generally is fighting the power
that's what you're supposed to do I
think as a comedian that's what most
great comedians do but here we have just
a group of people that are sort of going
to the lowest common denominator
constantly so again in free speech they
can say whatever they want but should
they be doing this within the social
context of what's going on James Franco
released a statement about what he feels
how he is gay or not gay or something
like that he said if that's what they
were going to make fun of for me I was
like great bring on the gay jokes
because these aren't insults at all I
don't even care if people think I'm gay
so it was like awesome I mean I wish I
was I wish I was gay and this is the new
thing where everyone always says I wish
I was gay Tom Daley the the swimmer the
British swimmer that everybody loves he
said this week he'd be cool if people
thought he was gay everyone's saying
this all the time now I think it's
slightly pandering but you know the
roasts have also changed you know they
used to be a group of friends people
that were big stars and friends like
Ronald Reagan and Frank Sinatra a
Lucille Ball that had inside jokes about
each other now it's just a bunch of star
[ __ ] basically trying to top each
other so they can get a show on Comedy
Central okay so as a comic Aaron I'm
going to start with you and I believe
you're a noted gay so when so we're
gonna go there for gay what do you make
this stuff cuz I I'm gonna venture to
say you're cool with that people saying
whatever they want joking about ever
they want but sort of the low-hanging
fruit here that they consistently go to
while gay people are still trying to get
a quality scene yeah you know this was
just another example of what happens in
comedy clubs across the country it's
just stupid straight dudes making stupid
gay jokes uh you know it's not creative
all those people up there like
you know there's some great comedians on
that dais I'm not going to pull each
comedian apart but you can just tell it
was just that really it was so stupid
and ridiculous because they clearly have
they don't know James Franco right and
so they're just like oh he's gay gay gay
gay
there was one clip of Aziz Ansari that I
thought was the best clip of the night
where he was just like oh you're
good-looking man and you're well
educated you read books that means dicks
are flying around your face I mean that
really said that all Ricky yeah that's a
joke he then turned the [ __ ] on that
and it's just you know honestly it is
it's absolutely ridiculous I had a
run-in with it with a comic uh in
Scottsdale last Thursday where he was so
disgustingly homophobic on stage and I
had to rip him a new one off stage and
then throw him under the bus on stage in
the entire crowd was with me like it's
it's just it's the lowest common
denominator it's super I honestly think
I have more of a problem with James
Franco saying like I wish I was gay than
all those d-bags saying oh you're gusta
giving your butt like it's so stupid
I think I was just like all right lean
so now I I said to Aaron that I believe
she's gay j.r i believe you're black if
i'm not according to my notes here uh
would you be offended if it had been a
black comic being roasted and a bunch of
white people because he if he is or
isn't gay these guys all aren't gay so
they've been a black comic being rose in
a bunch of white comics will endlessly
just making black children that's kinda
capital I mean if do remember the Comedy
Central Roast of Flavor Flav happened
it's exactly what happened when they
went after these ansari it was brownies
jokes but there was so many black
charcoal dark monkey jokes about Flavor
Flav because again that's the easy
[ __ ] you can come with yet because
that's it's the same idea over again now
I taught an overworld but I spoke with
jimmy dore about this and i was like
you're a comic let's almost talk about
this because I'm not so these things
have been altering for a minute because
they're not actually roasts do we forget
what roasts were personal these things
all written by the same guys you see the
credits is right yeah now you talk about
the old school ones where they would
actually talk about each other and if
reason one is because kimete
and can come up with things on top of
their head it's like and people like
more I don't care was it was kind of
funny I think but thing is they're
writing it off as a roast call it a
written [ __ ] talk yes night rather than
a roast gave me because I mean and some
people don't understand males like think
about if you're hip-hop fan don't when
people write there are there they're
lined you like that's cool but when
somebody says I'm a free stylist I can I
can freestyle watch me flow yeah and
then they can't do it or they write it
and read it they call themselves artists
you go no that's not a freestyle right
it's not what it was so we sort of think
of the roasts as the old things that
they used to be and you guys can go on
YouTube and check out some amazing
roasts like some classic comics and
politicians truly roasting each other
because they knew each other so is this
is the real problem here just sort of
that I think as comics we think because
the word comedy is in Comedy Central
that it's for all comics it's it's
comedy it's everything show is for great
men from 18 to 35 that's the humor
that's their target audience you know
they barely you know they're not
insanely supportive of really anything
outside of that demographic and that's a
Democrat it's like you know Noah my
you're gay you're gay you're gay it's
it's so I mean that's what I had to talk
to that kid about on Thursday I was like
he's like oh if I took out he literally
said the word [ __ ] on stage and I said
he goes I'm sorry didn't mean to offend
anyone he said if I took that word out
and I put gay would that be okay I go no
no that wouldn't be okay I go as a
straight man you you really how about
stick to stuff you know and not like you
know be creative about something else
and all those dudes up on the dais for
that roast it was just the same stupid
joke about big yeah I have to admit that
for a second I sort of didn't want to do
this segment because I don't want to be
the guy that's policing the comics or
that's even policing the words or even
placing the gay thing like it's endless
gay stuff all the time but I did feel
that you know so much goodness can come
out of comedy because of the the social
change it affects and telling the truth
and all that but I felt like I had to
well it's just it's you know what it is
at the end of day it's been done and
it's boring you know ii mean so get over
it and write some some things that are
more creative and interesting really and
on that note i hope this hasn't been
done before and it wasn't boring for you
so get over yourself and subscribe it's
right down there I want to thank Aaron
Foley jr. Jackson I'm Dave Rubin we're
switching studios by the way this is our
last show in this young turks studio
we're moving on to bigger and better so
I hope you've enjoyed the ride while we
did it but we'll be in a new studio
starting next week thank you for
watching and we'll do it again next week